vraiment
c'est vrai je t'adore comme Géraldine
j'ai de la chance pour mon premier
conseil de classe je t'adore et je
trouve tu es un orateur fantastique
quand je t'écoute je bois tes paroles
j'ai l'impression que je te vois la
tribune je te verrais même te lancer en
politique tellement tu pourrais mettre
au même titre que que Mélenchon quand
ils sont une tribune tout le monde
t'écoute et j'ai fini par te croire
malheureusement j'en ai très bien parce
que je t'imaginais la journée les
vacances et ton camion livreur boum boum
boum boum comme ça faire les livraisons
comme ça et malheureusement je me suis
réveillé et je suis en suis rendu compte
que l'homme ne réagisse était en fait
l'homme des palaces
tu nous fais croire que le soir tu
rentres chez ta femme tranquillou
j'apprends qu'on te voit dans tous les
palaces parisiens avec les plus belles
filles de Paris en train de boire des
cocktails
à midi à midi quand tu es censé livrer
toujours dès que je passe quelque part
ah bah il y a Raymond qui est venu qui
est venu boire un verre il était avec
Cyril comme ça
l'après-midi tes censé toujours livré ta
Roland Garros à Monaco je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu aimes les gens les gens t'aiment ça
se voit ça se ressent dans un sens et
dans l'autre je l'ai vu aussi en
vacances quand tu faisais la star et que
c'était dans les cafés pour boire un
verre alors qu'on devait juste voilà
bref j'ai parlé des détails mais moi je
suis Raymond moi c'était PMP non on
était en vacances et il a décidé de
vouloir s'asseoir là et pas ailleurs moi
je disais au patron du bar bah c'est bon
on va ailleurs on s'en fiche et lui il
avait décidé bah que non on serait là
parce qu'on était remonté
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu es mon super pote j'ai rien à dire
j'aurais voulu de mettre 10 mais c'est
marrant à chaque fois qu'on a des débats
tous les deux et que je parle avec toi
c'est long je m'en prends plein la
tronche après sur les réseaux c'est là
où je dis toutes les dingueries que j'ai
dit dans ma vie dans l'émission donc
c'est qu'en fait c'est j'ai l'impression
que je suis avec mon pote et que je suis
chez moi avec toi et il est là le
malheur donc du coup je te l'avais un
point et je t'ai mis 9
alors c'est pas mal
c'est une belle note oui Patrick Raymond
l'abominable
odeur des kammthaar aujourd'hui on est
le 20 juin 2023 et j'aimerais que tu te
repenses à une conversation qu'on a eu
il y a un an jour pour jour on était
tous les deux en vacances et tu te
moques de caviar non
mais vous êtes
des il sortait d'une saison incroyable
de TPMP
une fois que tu es au top c'est
difficile de faire encore plus haut il
savait pas si elle allait continuer mais
cette année tu t'es surpassé après avoir
fait Billie Jean tu nous a fait thriller
à chaque intervention standing ovation
du public des répliques cultes comme
c'est nous qu'on paye
[Applaudissements]
il y a aussi bien sûr on a les bonnes la
gamelle
vous allez me prendre pour un fou et
enfin ça explique la plus célèbre le
prix du gruyère il est à 95000
je suis mon abominable meilleur d'entre
nous donc je t'ai mis un disque
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
parce que on a été faire un foot et on
y va
et c'est nous qu'on a gagné
bébé alors moi Raymond oui
j'ai trop donné Raymond je pourrais te
mettre 10 parce que pour moi tu es le
chroniqueur qui est le plus on aime tes
coups de gueule tu es le plus sincère
dans tes dans tes appartements on aime
tes coups de cul parce qu'on t'a
découvert danseurs et vraiment à danseur
sexy
tu t'es révélé à la danse vraiment on
aime tes coups de parce que je pense que
tu as dragué à peu près tout ce qui
bouge ici
bureau plateau public
c'est quand tu parles à très peu de mecs
tu crois que dès qu'un mec parler
je suis une personne il est juste
vraiment je lui dis il est assez chaud
Marrakech
je suis désolé
tu es avenant avec toutes les toutes les
femmes
toutes les femmes sauf avec moi donc je
ne te mets que 8 voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors pour te noter Raymond il faut
savoir d'abord qui tu es Raymond Abou
qui es-tu alors c'est pas une question
en l'air qui est déjà on dirait une
émission de Mireille du monde c'est pas
une question suspendue comme ça c'est
une vraie question existentielle et moi
je me pose la question alors pour moi tu
es un l'homme le plus populaire de TPMP
c'est indéniable tes chauffeurs livreurs
ancré dans le réel contrairement à nous
bande de Oasis totalement hors sol bon
après tu fais de la télé de la radio
depuis plus de 15 ans mais bon passons
alter ego tu as un sniper absolument
redoutable et on l'a vu cette année
comme jamais alors après tu es un peu
parfois le Mister France de la démagogie
après tu as ta première dauphine Daniel
Moreau
des séducteurs auprès du public féminin
ça je pense que Guigui et moi on en est
tous témoins je confirme tu es aussi le
baromètre de Cyril c'est sa boussole tu
es son GPS en fait en gros si tu n'es
pas d'accord Cyril n'est pas d'accord le
public de TPMP est pas d'accord il est
téléspectateurs sont pas d'accord si si
tu es complètement dans l'ADN de TPMP du
coup tu as la pression alors
heureusement tu es un sportif et un
ancien sportif de haut niveau et donc
toi la pression ça devient
Cyril derrière
galvanisé par la pression tu sais très
très bien la gérer c'est pour ça que je
vais t'enlever quelques petits points
par-ci par là d'abord un je pense que
Guillaume est d'accord avec moi
attention Boulard Raymond
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoute je connais pas hyper bien mais je
peux pas
c'est pas du tout au contraire je t'aime
beaucoup ce que j'aime le plus chez toi
c'est vraiment ton côté passionné je
trouve que tu es parmi nous la personne
la plus passionnée quand tu parles c'est
vrai que je cligne plus des yeux je te
regarde et je bois tes paroles j'entends
chaque mot que tu me dis alors que
parfois certains autres je suis je pars
un peu ailleurs mais toi je suis
toujours vraiment focus sur toi parce
que parce que tu es un très bon orateur
comme le disait Jean-Mi et ce que j'aime
aussi beaucoup chez toi c'est que même
quand il y a des débats forts que ça se
cache un peu toi et moi parfois on parle
fort on sort d'ici dans le couloir je me
souviens les premières émissions tu m'as
fait un check tu m'as dit ah cool bonne
émission et bien vraiment tu vois
pendant l'émission Ça peut falter et en
dehors de l'émission Tout tout s'arrange
et c'est ce que j'aime d'ailleurs en
règle générale la TPMP c'est que peu
importe les avis dans le couloir tout
s'arrange et c'est voilà donc pour ça je
te mets une note plutôt sympathique de 8
et demi
Valérie alors mon Raymond en fait tu es
vous êtes Géraldine étoile et deux
phases une même pièce elle est hautaine
tu es populiste c'est la même pièce mais
c'est les deux faces complètement
différentes et évidemment elle l'a dit
t'étais démago tu es soupe aux lettres
et grande gueule mais tu as une qualité
qui emporte tout c'est la sincérité tu
es soupeé de façon sincère tu es démago
de façon sincère des populistes de façon
sincère et ça ça n'a pas de prix et puis
en plus tu es en face de moi pendant
toutes les missions que dans ma
diagonale et dans ma diagonale le truc
c'est que tu on se marre et que tu es
très très drôle et que je vois toutes
tes mimiques et tu fais beaucoup de
mimiques pendant l'émission en fait
c'est le fils du mime Marceau le gars en
fait pendant toute l'émission il fait
des commentaires mais juste avec son
visage et en fait voilà et était très
darka tu es très drôle les gens je sais
pas si ils savent à quel point en fait
tu es vraiment drôle et puis là cette
année en plus tu t'es mis à danser tu
t'es mis à draguer tu t'es mis enfin
il s'est mis à jouer le jeu
voilà en plus d'être sincère et d'y
aller avec tes tripes je te mets un 8
allez on va passer à ma note
[Rires]
chauffeur livreur le jour enfin surtout
le lundi
tous les autres soirs aussi célèbre j'ai
testé dans les cafés que vous livrez le
matin que sur les dents de Flore sur
lesquels vous pratiquez l'autre soir
avec l'art du contre-pied à un peu
maladroit après sur les terrains de foot
de seconde zone
[Rires]
réellement vous êtes unique un démagogue
pour les uns et puis pour les autres le
roi du franc-parler mais surtout Raymond
vous êtes l'homme qui divise l'homme qui
divise et vous divisez pas seulement
parce que vous êtes l'ami intime de
Cyril Hanouna parce que la jalousie
règne ici et parce que vous êtes un
homme de conviction au nom de cette
division que vous incarnez je vais vous
noter avec toutes mes convictions ma
note de départ elle est de 5 comme vous
divisez je divise aussi
[Rires]
c'est un deux et demi
j'arrondis à deux par pure amitié
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que voilà je j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup de potes et c'est vrai que
Raymond vraiment moi je suis d'accord
avec lui à 95% à chaque fois du temps
c'est vraiment celui qui me représente
le plus autour de la table celui en qui
je me reconnais le plus dans ces prises
de parole r dans ses opinions dans ces
et dans ces vannes donc c'est vrai que
voilà et Raymond voilà c'est en plus il
sait tout faire c'est à dire qu'il est
bon dans le débat il est bon dans la
rigolade il est bon dans la danse et une
seule chose qui est pas bon il est un
peu timide avec les meufs
je sais que voilà avec le temps avec le
temps ok va reprendre confiance en Lui
c'est rien ça c'est un petit alors c'est
un déclic c'est vrai que c'est mon
frérot c'est vraiment un de mes
meilleurs amis donc voilà beaucoup de
temps avec lui on va passer beaucoup de
temps ensemble cet été encore et c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment mon frère et
quand Raymond n'est pas là c'est pas la
même j'ai envie de venir bien entendu je
suis content d'être là mais je sais que
je vais pas faire la même rigolade voilà
donc c'est vrai que mon Raymond c'est
mon Raymond et vraiment je suis fier de
lui parce qu'il vient pas du tout
de voilà lui il a fait il a pas fait
d'école journaliste il a pas fait de
t'aider avant parce qu'il a fait toute
sa carrière avec moi c'est-à-dire que
non mais c'est vrai donc c'est ça qui
est fou moi je l'ai connu je le mettais
dans la rue en radio et puis il a su
évoluer et quand je l'ai mis en plateau
à l'époque il m'a dit plateau je saurais
pas faire tu vois peut-être après mon
plateau etc il m'avait dit la même chose
quand je lui ai présenté sa première
meuf
pédophile en aiguille voilà il a appris
sur le temps
et donc Raymond pour tout ça pour ton
année exceptionnel pour tes coups de
gueule pour tes danses pour
tes régimes que tu n'as jamais fait
et pour toutes les rigolades on a fait
et qu'on va faire je le dis pour moi
Raymond et cette année je lis le
meilleur élève de la classe
si on peut dire et je lui mets un 10
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors je te sens je le sens émue mon
rêve parce que tu l'as dit en fait moi
je viens pas de live au début je voulais
pas je dis je vais me cramer moi de
faire je sais pas mon poste et les
premières émissions que je fais je suis
à côté je suis à côté de Géraldine la
première émission j'avais retrouvé la
photo et je suis spectateur il y avait
qui à côté à ma gauche